Life as we know it started about 8,000
years ago and all the 24 billion years
old nonsense is just a bunch of Lies
cooked up by atheists liberals and other
assorted
hippies that's interesting I'm glad that
one's in there cuz I actually don't
know if you're one of these young
Earth I'm going say yes I'm I'm going to
say that you are I have a tough answer
on this of course you do but to to get
the point at least I'm going to say no
but here's my view which really could
fall into either category I do not have
any strong
theological not not a strong theological
need or anthropological or historical
need to say that the Earth is 8,000 let
me just clarify one thing I didn't think
you had a theological reason to to say
that the Earth is 8,000 years old I
figured it was contrarian purely contrar
I thought that that's what would lead
you there the issue is I don't need the
first chapters of Genesis to be read
literally